[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from the East Village in New York City
we're headed to Dan and John's Wings a
spot run by a pair of Buffalo natives
who decided that they couldn't find
buffalo wings good enough for them in
New York City so they opened up their
own spot and we're here for the real the
no-frills wings that buffalo nians have
been snacking on for decades
dan Borowski and John Hennigan opened
their doors early so that I can set my
wing game up and you can do at home
let's do this thing together what's
going on guys welcome to damage on wings
I'm Dan Dan John Richard nice to meet
you guys hope to meet you
alright so right when I walk in you know
I see Thurman Thomas football cards on
the walls I see a Jim Kelly bobblehead I
see a buffalo staring at me in the eyes
can you talk about that great weird City
of Buffalo New York and it's sort of
role in the buffalo wing movement
absolutely man you've actually finally
landed in what we call little Buffalo
right here in the middle of New York
it's our home away from home you know we
came from Buffalo we were born there we
were raised there and we wanted to
recreate buffalo chicken wings is the
most authentic way we can for New York
City people you know I think that a lot
of people to when they're watching this
video they might be intimidated like I
don't have an industrial fryer like I
don't have all these things I can't make
wings at home but that's not true is it
no we can show you how to make them at
home just as good as we do here the only
difference is the buffalo love that we
put inside every order all right let's
get this buffalo love going how it makes
them well absolutely now me and Jon are
I guess what you would call bird nerd so
a lot of this stuff isn't sounding a bit
technical that's good we got a lot of
bird nerd watching all right right on
the first thing you want to get
obviously is some fresh like Jon said
cut chicken wings right the most
important thing is you go all over the
globe and some of these people still
have the chicken wings connected at the
elbow or as I like to call it the the
Miep it which you don't want that you
just want your you want your drums to be
drum and you want your flat to B flat if
they're other they look like the letter
Z you're already off on the wrong foot
the next step is going from bold the
baskets the oil we've set our super
technological timer here in 13 minutes
we're going to let shot hit the start
button still very involved and then
during the course of the cook it is only
13 minutes button you should be shaking
the wings or if you're at home stirring
the wing kind of pry them apart a little
bit without being too forceful and I'll
rotate them around make sure they're all
getting crispy make sure they're all
getting equal amounts of heat so the
people at home if you don't have a fryer
if there's some way that you can
recreate that sort of effect at all
cookie pot and fill it about a third
with oil get that heated up to about 365
and you'll be able to do it what we have
over here is our sort of degrees of heat
going up ready we start with our mild
then we go medium then we go hot then we
go infernal if you're out there and
you're going to the store what should
would you recommend for the best classic
most authentic Buffalo salving I mean
that's a no-brainer as far as you know
John and I are concerned and most
Buffalo nians Franks original red hot is
the sauce that makes the wind will go
round if you want to get that classic
Buffalo flavor and you're not trying to
go with all the crazy heat for a mild
wing you go three portions butter melted
butter 1 portion hot sauce as far as
medium goes you're going to go the other
way around
so so we tend to go 3 portions hot to
one portion butter and then with hot
you're just going with straight hot and
then you just keep crime in crime and
climate you add those little secret
touches of you know pepper love but
other than that pretty basic we always
tell our workers don't feel like you
need to skimp on stuff like tossing
right no because the most important part
is you definitely want every wing to get
that coverage that's it man equal
coverage that's another big problem with
some of the the hackers out there you
know we like to squeeze bottle method
because it actually allows you to get
into every nook and cranny that the wing
and and you could do that at home you
know I mean like squeeze bottles are not
a rare thing to find if you don't and
you just want to dump this often then
you're just going to make sure that
you're getting full coverage so I have a
little method here that's kind of like a
thin twirl flip thing right right get
around like that and then I kind of like
me the fitment and then you know
sometimes we slo-mo this down do camera
tricks and get all fancier than we need
to be about it if we're going to be
keeping it Buffalo which is sort of the
way that we founded this whole thing
right got to get the celery stick we got
to get celery right some people like to
do carrots but we're trying to stick
like we said to the original original
idea and where we come from celery and
blue cheese is the original accoutrement
I was going to ask you that because
that's a big thing like it's ranch okay
or not so the people is where the wing
was invented
you know ranch is a salad dressing and
blue cheese is a chicken wing and
there's really no in between
alright I'm going to eat but to the hot
ones fans at home you now have the
step-by-step and how to make your own
wings keep doing the challenges keep
sending them to us I'm gonna eat guys
yeah thanks for having me anytime man it
tastes like victory right okay this
tastes like a foot ball game so I mean
that is the highest compliment it we
take it aside
[Music]